it's been a while since I've made a
decluttering video and I don't know
about you but I can never get enough of
decluttering ideas because no matter how
many times we declutter
sometimes items just creep back into our
homes or the things that we once used no
longer serve their intended purpose so
today I'll share with you 12 items that
I'm decluttering this month as well as
some ideas and tips to help you figure
out what items and categories you can
get rid of in your own home and be sure
to stick to the end for the one that was
the most difficult for me to get rid of
and to see what I did to finally be able
to discard it without guilt
first step is freebies and freebie apps
for things that I don't need or that
harm my health I'm not saying I never
accept freebies or that I never eat junk
food but I've had a change in mindset
where in the past I would accept any and
every free item offered to me and think
it's free why not take random objects in
my home that I'll never use if they're
free or have a softer ink or pizza every
week because I built up the points for
it the reality is that it's not free if
I load my home with random freebies I'll
never use I'll have a more difficult
time finding the things that I actually
need spend more time cleaning and
organizing and if I treat my body
without regard to what I'm putting in it
food wise eventually I'll pay it back
when the inflammation takes its toll and
I'm finding myself at doctor's offices
trying to manage the damage I've done
over the years so I had an open
conversation with my kiddos and
explained that I was deleting a Rewards
app that gave us free pizzas at gas
stations and if we really want a pizza
we'll just make a much healthier version
at home load it with veggies and have a
fun time doing it sometimes it can be
easy to declutter the items that cost us
money up front but it can be really easy
to overlook the freebies that are
costing us in the long run uncomfortable
shoes I have a pair of nursing shoes
that I spent quite a bit of money on a
few years back because I really wanted a
shoe that would help maintain better
posture and avoid aches and pains but
for some reason when it came to dress
shoes and heels I used to prioritize
Beauty over comfort those days are long
gone I had one Mary Jane Pump shoe that
I could dance in for hours and a pair of
wedges that always left me with hip pain
every time I wore them so I've sold
these to a consignment shop for a bit of
cash even if they're pretty go through
your own closet and either sell or
donate any shoes that either you never
wear or that cause you any pain teas and
drinks I did not like if you've watched
my channel for for a bit it's no secret
that I love a good latte coffee or tea
but in the past if I tried a tea I
didn't like the Savor in me would force
myself to drink every last cup until the
entire box was finished because I didn't
want to waste any it's embarrassing to
admit that it just never occurred to me
that I could gift them to someone else
who might actually enjoy them or just
toss them rather than chastise myself
for having made an erroneous purchase so
go through your trial drinks and snacks
and if you didn't like them give
yourself permission to get rid of them
rarely use spices if you've watched a
few decluttering videos chances are
you've looked through your cupboards and
spices for expired items but what about
those unused or rarely used spices I
love to cook with spices but as I was
going through my spices recently I
realized that I have some that I
actually never use either I just never
have recipes that need them or my
recipes need them but I don't like their
taste so for example Ginger is one of
those I know is super healthy and
awesome for you but I never use it
cloves are used in lots of Mexican
dishes but I rarely cook authentic
Mexican dishes and if I randomly decided
to do so no doubt my mom will have me
covered on all the Mexican spices I
could need so check through your spices
and Seasonings and if you have some that
you can't even remember the last time
you used chances are you can declutter
it old socks that have stretched out or
keep falling down a couple of years back
I bought a pack of all black socks to
avoid time having to find pears but my
plan failed as I purchased a very cheap
brand that ended up with stretched out
elastic way too quickly so I did what
any good wife would do and now I just
steal my husband's socks problem solved
least favorite duplicates this can be a
huge category if you're just beginning
with minimalism go through your entire
house and ask yourself if you have a
similar item that you prefer less than
the other for example if you have two
very similar shirts and rarely wear one
but always seem to gravitate towards the
other keep the favorite and consider
getting rid of the one you don't like I
had two sets of ice cube trays and
realized that I never use my silicone
trays because they're difficult to pop
the ice out of so these will go in the
Donate pile and I'll be keeping the ones
that I actually use
unused bulky furniture
not only can you make money by selling
larger Furniture pieces but often when
we're trying to declutter our homes it
can feel like we're not making any
progress because we're tackling smaller
items a few years back my husband and I
sold a large chest that came with our
bed set because we bought them used we
basically ended up getting our current
set for 500 now that we've decluttered
even more much of our drawers are unused
space so we plan on selling our current
set and having my husband make a simple
bed out of natural wood furniture and
the flat surfaces they provide are often
the first place we want to leave our
random objects on and it's almost as
though they beg for us to fill their
empty drawers if you're trying to open
up more space in your home consider what
large furniture piece is always in the
way and maybe you can even make some
money off of it
interchangeable chargers for different
devices as we get new or different
gadgets we tend to accumulate cords and
cables but I recently went through our
drawers and bins and realized that we
have four of the same chords that could
be used for our different devices I kept
two because we can charge two
rechargeable batteries at a time but the
others are just extra clutter to sift
through unused old phones my husband had
a phone stashed away in a closet from
years back that we had completely
forgotten about so I drove to our
nearest ecoATM and sold it right on the
spot for some quick cash this is a great
way to recycle an old phone that you
never plan on using again while also
getting some money out of it I'm not
sponsored by the way just sharing how I
sold mine toxic cleaners over the years
I've swapped out most of our cleaners
for vinegar baking soda and Castile soap
but I finally convinced my husband to
use vinegar instead of bleach because
bleach irritates my Airways so bad it's
toxic and I don't want to use toxic
cleaners in our home I've gotten enough
exposure to dmdm and other harmful
chemicals from working in a hospital for
years often the things we use every day
such as the forming toilet cleaner the
Degreaser have carcinogenic effects on
our body and if I can use the healthier
option in our home I most definitely
will opt for that books that I have
already read books for me are a
Sentimental item I love the feeling of a
well-made cover the smell of both new
and old books and the feel of cozying up
to a good book with a warm drink
probably a latte
but I recently decided to donate some of
my most love books to our local library
crucial conversations as one that I have
read and reread and I may want to read
again but I don't see a sense in keeping
it stashed away until maybe in the
future if that day does come then I'll
check it out at the library and in the
meantime the people in my community will
have had the chance to learn from the
books that helped improve my life and
lastly number 12 my childhood artwork
that I was once proud of this is
definitely a Sentimental category for me
my parents recently cleaned their
basement and found some of my old
artwork from when I was a child my
immediate Instinct was to take them home
with me and save them until I realized
even though they were once loved by me
I no longer had a space in my home and I
didn't actually want to display them I
was faced with a dilemma it may sound
odd but I had a mini remembrance
ceremony I looked through my artwork I
reminisced on the good times
I took photos of them and I said goodbye
letting go of sentimental items can be
incredibly difficult for me it was
easier when I allowed myself a time to
be grateful for the Memories they
brought and allowed myself to close a
previous chapter in order to open a new
one
and to look for the future
with a gratitude for the past
thank you so much for watching if you
like this video please give it a thumbs
up and help support my channel And
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
so you won't miss when I post a new
video
until next time bye for now
foreign
[Music]